you know in this chaotic day and age
it's important to stop and remember
what's gonna stick with you for the rest
of your life what's really important or
we can talk about prom prom so promise
the disney story about the prom which I
gotta admit me watching this movie I
felt like a pedophile in the movie
theater I'm just sitting there watching
a movie about prom but there's a part of
me that can kind of understand where
this movie's coming from because every
generation every ten years or so has
their high school movie whether it be
Dazed and Confused can't hardly wait or
American Pie now prom the only thing
prom is PG so it's yeah not really high
school ish it's a movie about prom in
high school for kids who watch the
Disney Channel so you got a bunch of
high school characters that are usually
in high school movies you know you got
the shiny normal kid you got Little Miss
Perfect you got the guy who actually
badass but has a heart deep down inside
that wrong movie sorry and there
are a few characters in this movie but
ultimately the main story or story
revolves around the guy who's you know
he pretends to be hardcore and the chick
who's almost perfect they get paired
together to put together prom yeah even
when you're in your twenties it's kind
of fun to look in on these movies and be
like oh yeah that that's me right there
there's just like that kid and then you
remember you can be doing anything else
but most anyone can relate to a
character in this movie I was
straight-up nerd I didn't even go to my
prom I honestly stayed home so I can
beat Metal Gear Solid true story that's
what happened really didn't come out of
my shell until you know 19 I mean it
comes down to the acting is not that
great the characters aren't that
established because they're supposed to
be Hollow because they're supposed to be
characters that you fill in with
yourself you're supposed to see yourself
in them like a mirror and
ultimately if you're one of the naive
people who believes that promise the
end-all be-all of human existence and
you're gonna like the movie prong
because that's what it's all about if
you're one of the realists who knows
that you're not gonna remember prom like
after you graduate because it's a fact
you won't pin you'll give the rating
that I'll give it which is I'm not gonna
say it's alright it's just that you
won't remember it in t-minus your
graduation there are movies that I
remember loving in high school that I'm
sure if I watch them now will be like
what's the point of that I'm sure this
is one of those movies like it's not
meant to reflect back on it's meant to
enjoy in the moment as you're in high
school moment you graduate irrelevant
but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more